أين كنت عندما تلقيت
الأخبار جيدًا ، كنت نائمًا في واشنطن
العاصمة ، كنت قد حصلت للتو في الليلة السابقة
من سان فرانسيسكو ،
وأظن أنني سمعت جرس الباب وأعتقد
أنه خمسة أشياء أبحث عنها ، أرى أنها
خمسة من هم  يجب أن تكون الشقة الخطأ ،
لا ، إنها ترن مرة أخرى ثم
Bang Bang Bang Bang Bang Bang على
الباب لذا ركضت إلى الباب
وأنا خائفة جدًا من رؤية شرطة الكابيتول هذه
وقالوا إنه يتعين علينا الحضور
للتحدث معك و  أنا أفكر في
أطفالي أحفادي الذين لم أفكر أبدًا في
أنهم سيكونون بول لأنك
تعلم أنني كنت أعرف أنه لن يكون بالخارج
وأنت تقول دائمًا ، لذا
جاءت أم في ذلك الوقت لم نكن نعرف حتى
مكان وجوده أو  ما هي حالته
التي عرفناها للتو أنه كان هناك اعتداء
عليه في منزلنا والآن كانوا
ينقلونه إلى مستشفى تبين أنها
سان فرانسيسكو جنرال التي تقود
مركز الصدمات والحمد لله لقد ذهبوا إلى هناك
لم يكن الأقرب  لدينا مستشفيات
على بعد مبان قليلة لم تكن الأقرب
لكنه كان المكان المناسب للذهاب إليه ،
حيث تعرض للضرب في رأسه
بالمطرقة في الأعلى مباشرة ، وشغل
مكانين وهذا أمر
مروع للغاية ، لكن الخبر السار
كان عندما جاء عندما أجرى
العملية  وقد باركنا
محترفو الرعاية الصحية في سان
فرانسيسكو جنرال
أم أخبرونا أنه لم يخترق
دماغه الذي كان يمكن أن يكون مميتًا أو
أسوأ ، لذا فإن المطرقة لم
تصحح في الواقع ، لا ، لقد تصدع ، حسنًا ،
ما يجب عليهم فعله  ما يجب عليهم فعله هو
خلع الجمجمة وإعادة تشكيلها
وإعادتها مرة أخرى حتى لا تخدش أو تخترق
الدماغ ، لذا فهي
عملية خطيرة جدًا وهناك
دائمًا قلق بشأن التورم أيضًا
دائمًا ما يهتم دائمًا بالوقت مع
كل ما تبقى ولكن  أخبرني ابني بول
أنه عندما رآني ركبت الطائرة على
الفور للذهاب إلى كاليفورنيا ولكن
أممم ،
لكنه خرج الآن من العملية
وقال بول إن والدتي في طريقها إلى هنا
وقال بول أول شيء قاله
يا  ستكون والدتي سعيدة للغاية
لأن الغربان فازت الليلة الماضية
وهذا ما قاله زوجك من
العملية ، نعم وصلنا إلى بالتيمور أنت
تعرف اتصال بالتيمور الخاص بي ، لذلك
اعتقدنا جيدًا أنه معه ،
تعلم أنه يتذكر فوزهم ومن الواضح
يعرف لي بعد 49ers تفاني
في الغربان